[Music]
hey everybody
yep louie's in there what's going on
yeah lou hernandez is in there
is everybody still sleeping or hungover
or what yeah they're just starting to
show up
i got up at 7 30. i remember it being a
good show last night
i did too yeah um i was pretty hammered
at the end
i remember it being pretty good i mean i
feel like we covered i know it was like
an
hour and five minutes or something
before we even started talking about the
case
yeah no but i i did like somebody
commented they're like it you know it'd
be cool if you like actually put hey
you're gonna like start talking about
the case at whatever time so i actually
did start doing that yeah
we take about an hour to warm up to go
through all this
it takes a while well i feel like i
didn't go through like all the details
and everything because i feel like a lot
of people that's a very famous case and
a lot of people know about it
so i feel like i just wanted to kind of
go into
some [ __ ] that was in that book that i
read that i actually didn't know about
the case that i thought maybe a lot of
people wouldn't know about it
so i know it was kind of rambling but
what else is new all of our shows are
rambling aren't they
but uh yeah so it's sunday today i just
been doing the
[ __ ] with the polls for next week's show
i've been wrapping christmas presents
yeah i wrapped all the kitties christmas
presents
put them under the tree so hopefully
they don't get in there and
tear them up so like i smell catnip in
there i've been having terri i've been
having sinus problems i think it's
starting to
go away though woke up this morning
smelling like it smelled like cigarette
smoke in here
nobody smokes in here yeah just burned
up [ __ ] nose follicles
[Laughter]
maybe in your sleep someone was like
sticking with
a lighter up your like a car later up
here no
this movie here was a korean movie this
is on netflix
it i think it was it's been on there
since the end of november and i kept
seeing it and like i saw the
preview of the trailer and i was like
man that looks pretty good and we've
been having good luck with the korean
horror lately yeah like we've seen a lot
of really good ones
and this is called the call now it's
kind of confusing it's it can also it's
i've also seen it called just call like
without the the
yeah but the thing is though that
there's also an american horror movie
that came out this year called the call
that has linshay in it uh who was in
like some of the conjuring universe
movies among
many other things so this is not bad
movie this is a different this is korean
and actually this is kind of a i don't
know if i'd call it a remake
or it's kind of based on this
british puerto rican film that was
called the caller that came out in 2011.
um i'm not sure i haven't seen that
movie so i don't know if like the
premise is the same
but this movie this was really cool
because i think when it first started
because it starts kind of slow and
you're not really sure i didn't really
know um
where it was gonna go like i knew it
involved a phone call obviously
um and that some weird [ __ ] was going on
that like some weird person was calling
this
our main character but i had no idea how
mind-blowy this film would be you know
what i mean like how twisty and turny
and it had almost kind of like
sci-fi type of elements to it yeah
and i thought that was really cool
because i wasn't expecting it
and i ended up even though it was like
it took me a while to get into it
because
at first it doesn't really seem like
that but it as it goes on
you know it it just kind of like gets
weirder and weirder and weird and then
like you just get
sucked into it like the more that you
watch it so if you start watching it and
you think
oh it seems boring or it doesn't seem
like a thriller or something like that
like
stay with it because it gets crazy
yeah that's kind of [ __ ] twisty yeah
you you don't know if it's
interdimensional or what are we talking
about time loops
certain elements that started to kind of
remind me of donnie darko not not quite
as artistic as daddy darko
yeah i like that damn german series dark
dark yeah it did it did give me a little
bit of that vibe
just thematically it kind of gave me
that kind of vibe but yeah so basically
what
i'll kind of just give i'm not going to
spoil it i had a hard time following it
actually
i think a lot of people did um but it's
not as hard to follow as dark
cause dark you needed like [ __ ]
charts and there was like a big [ __ ]
if you go to the wikipedia page there's
this massive like big chart chart that
somebody made
this one is not that complicated um but
it is
kind of a head scratcher and probably
it's one that you would need to watch a
couple of times like just to make sure
that you got i got the gist of it but
like to pick up some of the details and
stuff
so basically like i said i'm not going
to spoil it but
you got um a young lady named kim
ceo yeon i know i'm probably pronouncing
that wrong she's 28.
uh i think she's played by park shanghai
who i think was also
in hashtag alive if i'm not mistaken
this is typical korean production value
which for right now is good
good score uh good looking cast
to to be to be in a korean movie you had
to be cute
that's not gonna say they want their
[ __ ] ugly [ __ ] and these if they
want their [ __ ] money's worth you
know what i mean like i paid this
i paid 10 bucks for this movie you show
me these ugly [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
that's where are the hot girls well it's
also it's also the guys too
where are the hot guys oh yeah oh yeah
you you gotta and even if they're older
they they have to be cute yeah oh this
is mainly there's a lot of female
characters in this there's a couple male
characters too but not that many it's
mostly like
focused on people here something that
kind of also happens in like uh
chinese and japanese cinema
they don't really allow ugly people to
be in there unless it's the character's
supposed to be
somebody who's a super unless that's
like part of the that's part of the
thing right yeah
which that's kind of the way it was here
in the united states up until recently
really
well here it's like if you're even now
like if you're
if you're ugly or you're not super
good-looking you're just a character
actually yeah
first ugly [ __ ] i saw in a movie
recently would be [ __ ] dave
david steve yeah yeah yeah but
there was something funny about him
though as he was kind of handsome in an
ugly way
yeah he's one of those people that's
like funny looking but kind of hot funny
looking yeah more you look at him you go
now he's kind of cool looking yeah
yeah that's what i mean yeah so it's
like it's all in how you work it man
yeah
but yeah so uh this young woman
at the very beginning you're not real
sure she's visiting her mom
like at a um hospital or some kind of
care home or something like that i guess
her mom has cancer is dying or whatever
and um they don't explain why at first
but her and her mom have a very uh
strained relationship let's put it that
way
so that's what you get at the beginning
and then she's taking the train home
and she loses her cell phone which is
kind of like a big
uh you know thing that you know drives
the platform
so she goes back to the old family home
and uh the guy that drove her was like
she's like hey i lost my cell phone you
know i can't like be without a phone
he's like oh there's probably like an
old cordless one in there like you know
why don't you
look for that it's maybe it's up in the
closet or the attic or whatever so she
finds the phone
she hooks it up and
she starts receiving mysterious phone
calls
from a girl who starts screaming that
her mother
is trying to kill her now
as the conversations between these two
girls
women go on you discover
that the woman on the other end of the
line who is also 28 years old
lived in this same house but back in
1999
so they are talking to each other on
this magical presumably magical phone
uh 20 years apart some kind of time warp
it's some kind of weird time but this is
not explained but it's not important
um it's just and and i feel like a lot
of asian
horror they're really good at doing this
like taking
some kind of mundane technology and like
making it scary
or making it like the center of a horror
plot well twilight zone did that
that's true yeah but i feel i feel like
that's kind of a hallmark of
uh a lot of really good asian cinemas i
like the ring uh
pulse that type of stuff um so
so you're basically getting these two
women communicating
across 20 years they're in the same
they're occupying the same
house but 20 years apart
and so one thing that happens
is that uh in the present
uh kimco yawn's dad died
when she was a little girl and it turns
out that the girl in the past
is like hey i could keep your dad from
getting killed because it hasn't
happened yet
you know what i mean so after that
um like i said i really really don't
want to spoil like all the twists and
stuff
because i couldn't keep all these twists
uh straight anyway you this is
definitely like i said it's definitely
one that you have to see
more than once but i've seen like a
because some people a lot of people have
reviewed this because like i said it's
netflix
and um so a lot of people have done like
review videos and then they did
another like a spoiler video where they
explained
like what happened so like i said i got
it mostly there was a couple things i
didn't pick up on like when i went and
read through the wikipedia plot
synopsis i was just like oh okay i
didn't get that
but mostly i got it i got where they
were coming from with it
yeah i mean it's the same thing you know
when i first saw donnie darko i didn't
understand it i'm not even sure i still
understand
it was just like that's some weird [ __ ]
donnie darko i feel like was
um kind of more complicated than this
one because
that one had like a whole bunch of
different characters like fates
intertwining which this one has two
but it's mostly concerned with
these two women and another thing too
is that this this time
thing isn't a loop it's kind of like
basically they're both moving through
time at like the normal rate
so for example let me see if i can like
say this without messing it up
for example like when 1999
chick is like oh hey your dad hasn't
died yet
i can prevent that because you know what
happened because you are in the future
from her point of view
so she's like i can prevent that
happening which will you know cause all
of these changes obviously like in your
reality
but once it happens in 1999
it can't be changed anymore it's not
like people can it's not like a time
travel movie where you can just
oh well we'll travel back in time to
before that happened and then we'll try
again
i feel like that's not happening so if
you
prevent someone from dying or if you
kill someone back then
like it can't be nobody can go back and
change it
and i think that i can't remember but i
think that her
calling the 1999 girl calling the 2019
girl
i don't think the 2019 girl could call
the 99 1999 girl i think it only went
that one way
you know what i mean because i think
every time it was like her phone was
would ring in 2019
and it was past chick you know what i
mean but i don't think she could call
past chick up and be like hey can you do
this and that for me can you
put some money in a bank or like her
like put put some money on
on this [ __ ] stock or something like
that i don't think she could do that
right and um as it turned out like i
said you would think that that would be
like a cool thing that would happen but
it
turns out that it doesn't uh shake out
that way
because past girl is um
maybe not as cool a person as you would
hope
so um so there's that but like i said
this is a really really if you like kind
of mind bendy like
like i said if you like dark or danny
darko or something like that like i said
it isn't as complicated as that
if you pay attention and you pay
attention to what everybody says you'll
get the gist of it
it's not that hard to figure out but at
the time of watching i wasn't quite in
the mood for it
yeah if i was in the mood for it i
probably would have enjoyed it a little
bit better it was just too
damn complicated i kind of wanted
something that was just more kind of
maybe funny and entertaining at the time
your mindset has a lot to do with yeah
because this one
this is another one where you really
have to it's not like already farty it's
not
or nothing like that but it's definitely
one that you have to pay attention to
but if you're paying attention to it and
like i said it does
it takes a while to get into that mode
because at first you're just kind of
like okay well this chick's just
visiting her mom and that she lost her
cell phone
and then she's getting these weird phone
calls and she doesn't really know what
it's for
and you don't really find out like about
the time travel and then like once that
starts
like [ __ ] starts getting [ __ ] crazy
and it's just
i got super super sucked into this movie
like it took a while
because i was sitting there going oh
this is pretty good you know but
it's kind of not going anywhere but then
like once that [ __ ] started happening i
was like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] like it
just kept
like ramping up so i thought it was like
really really good
but as i said you have to kind of really
it's one you really have to pay
attention to
um and i kind of feel like
they i don't want to say they left it
open for a sequel
but yeah they did i get yeah i guess
they could kind of make a sequel if they
wanted to
um or they could have just end they
could just end it where it is but they
could definitely like make a sequel to
this because they did leave it
and um another thing too is when it ends
and the credits
start rolling keep watching it because
something's done something else happens
yeah
[Laughter]
in the credits and it's actually kind of
really important um
so it changes like the whole end so yes
uh sandra asks how was the curry no i
said yeah sorry it was good
yeah it was delicious we had some for
lunch today too
and today we heated it up and we had it
with non-bread and it was
yeah delicious i'm thawing out some damn
beef i think i said thank you we found
something in the freezer froze
remember when we made it it's not from a
long time ago
maybe a month but i don't remember what
it was
it's it i think it's beef bottom round
i think i have no idea what it is i
don't remember they're like little
steaks but i forgot which ones they were
are they cooked or no no oh they're not
cooked oh okay it's eight of them eight
slices
i thought you cooked them and then put
them on no because they were frozen and
i couldn't tell what they were
no it's raw it's eight slices of some
kind of steak he comes in my office with
his big frozen bag
what are these yeah you might remember
well remember i don't remember what i
cooked with that aren't we funny
it's like what we put because like i
said when he makes food he makes like a
whole bunch and like so sometimes if we
get
sick of it or we don't want to eat
anymore yeah we'll you know portion it
out and put it in the freezer
and we have so much stuff in there that
every now and then we'll be like going
through there looking for some
vegetables or something be like what the
[ __ ]
what is this yeah can i eat it still
do you remember that one time you made
that humongous lasagna
yeah and i feel like there are there
still pieces of that in there
okay because i feel like there were
pieces of that in there for a really
long time that's okay though so i think
i think
uh some of that was on he was in there
for like two or three months i think
that's what i'm saying just like i
probably should have thrown it away but
i was like i'm a thought
and see what happens and see if it was
anything it was good it was still good
real good yeah so i said
we're gonna eat this yeah i mean some
things like like that lasagna if you
froze it because we froze it like
only a day or two after we made it and
yeah even two or three months later we
thought it out and we cooked it and it
tasted
exactly the same that's cause i packed
it right yeah you know i packed that
[ __ ] real tight and saran wrap and
[ __ ] wrapped it and wrapped it
wrapped it was almost basically vacuum
packed
so you know it was nothing could get
nothing to get in there
yeah so it was good but i think that was
i think this beef is the same beef i
used for something kind of like
stroganoff
or did i make some kind of steak
sandwiches i can't even remember
when we bought that when did we buy that
i don't know
i got that nice bread maybe i can make
steak sandwiches with we can have that
for dinner i guess yeah you want to take
sandwich yeah
i can make a steak sandwich uh i don't
have what it takes to make stroganoff
uh i can make uh that's probably too
fattening anyway yeah well everything's
fattening if i'm making it
that's true well let me see what else
i don't know i think a stick sandwich
sounds good i mean you know
okay that's what i'll do then we can
just have that we have to get we have to
use up that bread anyway that's what i'm
saying because that's bread's been in
there
a long time and i don't want that's not
a long time well it's been in there for
about five days six days
yeah it's refrigerated though you don't
want it to get yeah
stale it won't we'll eat it in time it's
it's those uh hoagie rolls
yeah yeah yeah hoagie rolls i like those
like
like for a sub sandwich i finally
finished up that
uh multi grain bread that we had a thing
over i got another loaf of that back
there oh you do oh okay that was some
good [ __ ]
yes we've been uh i've been making toast
with that yeah i got a case of eggs back
there
not a not a not a dozen eggs a case like
a case
a case of eggs we eat a lot of eggs yeah
i love eggs see
at the store i go to i can get an entire
case of eggs
i think for six bucks so why buy a
why buy a little one because we go i
mean we go through so many because we
not only i mean eggs are like super easy
like if you don't feel like really
cooking anything like it's just
you know easy to fry a couple eggs and
have some toast and hey it's dinner
but um i think it's six dozen eggs you
cook with them a lot too
six dozen eggs like six dollars yes
you know like i said we go through a lot
of eggs so
make all kinds of [ __ ] with them yeah we
do yeah see what everybody's saying
somebody said i got myself a food back
love it tammy said that
and victor says the foodie ninja girl
has a dehydrator setting
some orocomo is making cajun meatballs
those are pretty good
oh yeah i don't think i've ever read
those we've never made those have we
no made a lot of italian meatballs louis
said this movie sounds a little bit like
frequency it is kind of like that i had
forgotten about that movie but yeah
this i actually liked this better than
frequency but
frequency was okay too but i think
there's these little pakistani meatballs
that used to make things called kofta
yeah that's right yeah we made that a
few times yeah
they're not great though every recipe i
found i mean they're okay
it's just a meatball yeah it's not
mind-blowing not really mind-blowing
it's just kind of like a meatball but
with
slightly more and in a spicy gravy yeah
we haven't made it in a while though
yeah like because like i said they're
good but it's not like
i mean we're gonna make you know indian
or pakistani food or something like that
i always like
you know go to something else you know
what i mean that's like on there from
from saudi
and uh made me think of that arabic food
too man i haven't had kiwi in a long
time there was this
arab there was these little arabic
things
we used to eat when we were in egypt
and it was like a round piece of baked
bread and on top of it
um ground seasoned beef
and then you they used to um squeeze
like a
lime on it or lemon on it it was looking
really good i forgot what it was called
though
it's kind of like a little it's like a
little pastry you could just pick it up
oh okay you know what i mean it was like
i think i know what you're talking about
it's like a baked flat bun with ground
beef
spiced ground beef and i think sliced up
onions and stuff you know it was all
baked and
it was stuck to the top of it sad says
mota bak
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing that
right yeah something like that and then
you put lemon on it squeeze lemon on it
need it
that sounds yeah they had it in egypt
and uh i even saw that in israel so it
was just in that whole area people were
eating it
louie says yeah have i ever heard of
alice crimins i've heard that name but i
don't know a lot of the details about
the case so i will definitely look that
up because
i know i've heard that name though i
just can't remember in what context i
heard it
um sandra says aren't they with
chickpeas the kofta meatballs
or a chickpea dressing i think there's a
bunch of different variations of it
yeah i don't remember we made it a
couple years but yeah but
it's been a while since we made it i
don't know i don't think there was
chickpeas in it
just ate it just made it kind of like a
thin
spicy gravy you eat it with rice
we made a lot of indian dishes with
chickpeas
yeah like uh what is that what the
chana masala or whatever it is there's
another one
that's kind of that's pakistani popular
with pakistani
muslims called keema which is like a
ground beef stew
yeah we've made that a bunch of times
kind of lemony sometimes
spicy and lemony is good put it uh pour
it over rice
or put rice couple times we've made it
though it was like really hot way hot
yeah
it was really hot got to be careful with
the spice mixes that they sell for that
yeah you never know because sometimes uh
you know obviously we go to that
uh indian market or whatever it's like
spice land and
they have all they have a whole aisle of
different
spice mixes for different dishes and
you never know like they usually have
chan they usually have national
they have a couple of other ones i can't
remember what they're called
but you never know how
hot that's gonna be until you make it
somebody with a scan or the sand with a
sanskrit looking
[ __ ] screen name says it's called
arie res
i don't know exactly what you're talking
about the the little um
the little uh bread with uh with the
with the beef on top of it
yeah i don't know i don't know we'll
have to look it up after this because we
were talking about curious
now there was a lot of but you know
what's funny about that keema
is that the recipe that i followed it
had kind of a
thin stew or soup that went with it you
know what it was it was
yeah it wasn't like real thick stuff it
was kind of thin and like the meat was
ground really small yeah
and i was thinking at the time i was
like man that ought to be creamy
i bet you you could add yogurt to that
well i mean that's true of anything or
cream
everything's better
yeah it was a little too thin for me
yeah
yeah eryus arias sorry about pronouncing
that wrong beef
it's like a beef pasty yeah it's like
that it was a flat piece of bread
about that big around and in the middle
of it it was a little bit dished in the
middle of it a bunch of ground beef
and onions it's spiced and you take a
lemon or a lime and squeeze it on there
and eat it just like a handful it's good
yeah
really good i'm going to get the [ __ ]
out of that but yeah that is kind of
like a pasta
although that's like a middle eastern
hamburger yeah without a top without a
top on it yeah right yeah it's like that
okay that makes sense it's good yeah
yeah that's all right all right um so
you have anything else you would like to
say all right so if you have netflix
like i said if you're into korean horror
this is a really good one like i said
give it
it's very it's kind of slow to start out
but give it a chance because it gets
[ __ ]
crazier and crazier as it goes on and
you'll get like super sucked into it at
least i was
but yeah so uh we'll be back tomorrow i
think what i'm going to start doing
since our christmas special is next
arabic guys help me say it's bread
ground beef it's usually made in
charcoal yeah yeah yeah okay victor
garcia they look good i guess they're
looking at them they're saying you all
making me hungry yeah
don't we always because we always end up
talking about food
yeah victor i'm telling you man those
that arias thing that
that arabic hamburger i won't call it
beef pasty you know or
it's an arab hamburger all right that's
like something that they would just buy
and eat it while they were walking that
was good man it's real good
it especially with some lemon on it i
mean a pasty though is more like it's
like enclosed
that's like a pie it's like pie crust
this one was open like an open-faced
sandwich but it was portable you could
carry it yeah
yeah um but yes oh so what i was going
to say since next
saturday is going to be our christmas
special because i kind of debated i was
like well
the saturday following that is the day
after christmas so i feel like we should
do the christmas special before
christmas
you know what i mean so we're doing the
christmas special on the 19th and um
so i thought well leading up to that
most of our matinees
i was gonna do like some newer christmas
movies or christmas adjacent movies
christmas horror movies so uh that's
what i'm gonna start doing i've got like
a whole bunch of them picked out
that i'm gonna start doing tomorrow i
was actually gonna do one today but then
we watched this one
i really liked it so i wanted to talk
about it but yeah so starting tomorrow
we're going to do christmas horror
movies
all right so that'll do it for the
matinee today thanks everybody for
dropping by
and uh we'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye